there was a bit of a sort of second
honeymoon phase for Donald Trump early
in the corona virus pandemic and we
talked about it at the time his approval
rating on his handling of the corona
virus pandemic was actually not bad
early on his general presidential
approval had actually ticked up in
mid-march to close to 50% which is very
close to a high for Donald Trump's
presidency and this wasn't shocking and
as we talked about at the time there's
this historical a sort of rally around
the president tendency during times of
national crisis we saw after 9/11 for
example george w bush's approval spiked
dramatically to as high as 90% which is
it's almost unthinkable today of course
it was eventually squandered by george w
bush but then it spiked again as the
iraq war got going in early 2003 all the
way up to 71% approval and then again
that fell off for george w bush as that
war ended up being a completely
misguided disaster and donald trump had
a little bit of this in march back in
march his approval ticked up but as is
his administration's response to the
virus has tragically been one of the
worst in the world I mean I'm not gonna
say V worse but you have to look pretty
hard for leaders who responded more
poorly than Donald Trump did we have
seen Donald Trump experience the
sharpest drop in approval of his
presidency so far now the news here for
now is the rapid change so far okay the
absolute numbers are still in the normal
range for Trump's presidency his
approvals down to 43 that's not the
absolute low of his presidency his
disapproval spiked to 54 again that's
not the high disapproval of his
presidency but if you're looking at the
chart with me right now you see that
this is a very rapid nine-point jump in
disapproval since the last time Gallup
did the survey and a nine-point jump in
three weeks is the biggest fastest jump
in that time period during the
presidency now where will it go next we
don't know but it's clear that Americans
are on average realizing the disaster
that is Donald
handling a true crisis now his
supporters are still absolutely enamored
with his handling they now are
increasingly protesting for the
reopening of states with Trump
increasingly supporting them we'll talk
about that a little bit later but at the
national level on average Trump's
approval has declined very quickly over
the last three weeks now in the meantime
the polling for Joe Biden in the 2020
presidential election which is now just
six and a half months away continues to
be strong but I'm going to keep being
very careful about this all that I'm
telling you today is that right now six
and a half months before the election
there's a trend in which Joe Biden isn't
doing poorly against Donald Trump the
trend is that the country is as I said
already it's on average a country that
disapproves of Donald Trump and is a
country that on average is leaning
towards Joe Biden but things can change
quickly and remember that we have an
electoral college in the United States
so in the latest NBC news/wall Street
Journal poll Biden is plus seven over
Trump 49 to 42 that still leaves a full
nine percent unsure or with third
parties right now we then have a Harvard
Harris poll which has Biden plus six and
this one it's Biden 53 Trump 47 that one
has no undecided now this could mean
nothing by November and Trump may get
himself re-elected and so we have to be
very careful about inferring much at all
from this interesting also in North
Carolina Biden is now plus-one in a
recent poll Trump had actually been
winning in North Carolina in a bunch of
recent polls so that's a big flip the
caveat being this is a PPP poll PPP
polls are known for leaning Democratic
it may mean very little but if Biden can
stay close in North Carolina that's a
state that Trump won by 3 plus in 2016
if it's even if Biden is really plus one
in North Carolina that could set suggest
a worse outcome for Trump in 2020 than
he had in 2016 the important takeaways
are we're counting every vote we're not
opting out I'm speaking of
optimistically none of us are opting out
of the election we're pushing for
vote-by-mail in the expansion of
absentee ballots so that we can keep
people safe and voting in November
nothing changes for us as a result of
these numbers we want no one to die or
go without coronavirus care you know
Republicans are now trying to give some
oxygen to this theory that the left
wants more people to die from the virus
so that it will be bad for Donald Trump
Trump has already failed no one else
needs to die
for Trump to deserve being removed in
November and I think that that's the
important thing that we have to point
out every time they say you want a
higher death toll we say that's
absolutely ridiculous there's no
evidence of that and it's not about a
higher death toll to justify Trump's
removal Trump's rhetoric and actions to
date already justify his removal even if
the deaths went to zero today it's a
false premise
don't let them trick you into these red
herrings but also don't get lulled into
any sense of complacency because of
these numbers